divertissement massif ce sont
des temps dangereux un studio Ubisoft du
moins c'est ce que j'entends un chasseur TIE
traverse un vaisseau spatial bataille l'
Empire un tir retire le lien dans une
explosion enflammée ils sont partout un
destroyer stellaire apparaît hors de l'hyperespace
et un vaisseau adverse  s'écrase dessus
mais le monde ici un corps en carbonite
s'éloigne d'un membre chaud de la famille
envoyant dans le brouillard une silhouette fait tomber
une épée sur un être plus petit Film de Lucas
jeux dans une cantina une jeune brune
joue au sabak avec un groupe d'extraterrestres que je
veux  pour survivre ouais je dois jouer à
leur jeu sous la table, elle fait signe à une
petite créature avec un visage de gecko
qui regarde les cartes de son adversaire puis
revient vers elle on dirait que j'ai tout
faux maintenant un chasseur de prime montre son
image au  le barman qui montre la
brune dans laquelle elle se trouve ici quelque part une
seconde après avoir pensé que j'étais dehors, sa créature
détourne le tir du Blaster d'un adversaire qui
frappe un extraterrestre costaud au bar, une bagarre
éclate, le chasseur de primes tire
sur la brune
qui se précipite à travers la mêlée et s'échappe
avec sa créature sur ses talons
alors que le chasseur de primes et quelques autres lui
tirent dessus, elle court vers un speeder bike
garé parmi les pièces du navire en grimpant dessus, elle fait un
zoom arrière et lance des explosions dans son
dos.
J'ai été retenu toute ma vie, elle a
couru  une rue bondée avec sa
créature qui reste à proximité et maintenant
j'ai juste besoin d'une chance d'être enfin libre
dans une grotte. La brune protège ses yeux
de la lumière du jour qui afflue partout où cela
me mène.
Je suis là pour t'offrir une issue, d'accord,
descends de mon navire.  Jalen,
donne-moi une chance,
tu vas devoir me faire confiance, ce sera
dangereux, mais si tu réussis,
tu ne regarderas plus jamais par-dessus ton épaule
au ralenti. K abat un
poursuivant depuis son Speeder bike dans une fosse.
Rancor lève ses mains griffues debout
sur le bord d'une terrasse un homme barbu
dans une cape de fourrure regarde les enfers
ne montre aucune pitié au bord d'une falaise K
regarde à travers des jumelles macro mais c'est
une grande galaxie là-bas et je vais
le risquer
dans la bataille spatiale Kate Twirls et
tisse son vaisseau autour des vaisseaux explosifs
Star Wars Outlaws à venir en 2024.